*rien*
*Démarche naturelle*
*Stop*
C'est toujours terrible ce moment où je sais pas quoi faire en intro !
Les amis je vous ai demandé sur Twitter de m'envoyer des dessins en rapport avec moi et notre univers Youtube
*Clap de mains*
Sur le HashTag #SqueezieFanArt
Alors les FanArts c'est pas nouveau , j'en reçois tous les jours depuis plusieurs années
Et je voulais en vidéo , rendre hommage un peu aux gens qui font ça parce que c'est du temps
C'est des compétences
Et puis je pense que ca vaut le coût de de de
Mettre ça devant le projecteur finalement
Ou sous le projecteur , c'est mieux
Parce que devant le projecteur il est pas sous la lumière donc...
La, l'expression ne marche pas finalement
*Rigole*
*The Clap de main*
Regardons tous ces dessins ensemble
Et Merci ! On Commence avec un dessin simple et efficace. On dirait une fille. Excellent!
Il est très bien j'ai pas critiqué.
Oh pu*** #SqueezieFanArt. Djumbo nous manque !
Alors déjà tu l'insultes en mettant un "D" au début de son prénom
parce qu'il n'y a pas de "D", ça se dit "Djumbo" mais ça s'écrit "Jumbo"
et ensuite, ce chat sur cette photo est bien plus beau que Jumbo.
Et n'est certainement pas Jumbo ça c'est tout simplement (un) Angora.
Attention! Ah je suis un fils de p*** je critique les dessins aujourd'hui!
C'est bel et bien un angora.
Ok, maintenant je te mets un Jumbo!
Voilà! Ca n'a rien à voir, il est beaucoup plus moche, mais tellement mignon!
Ok, on continue! Ohh! Dites donc!
Fait par un youtuber qui s'appelle TutoDraw, pu****, il s'est fait ch*** hein?
Qu'est ce que je suis bonne mon gars!
*Voix de beauf*
Hé j'aurais pu pécho des mecs easy!
Ah j'en profite pour passer un petit mot, voilà j'ai vu la communauté des gens qui font des FanArts, un peu énervée parce qu'il y a plein de gens qui s'amusent à taper :
"nanana fanArt" sur Google et à voler littéralement le dessin voilà!
Et à le poster sur les réseaux et faisant genre que c'est lui même qui l'a fait!
Ne faites pas ça! C'est vraiment pas cool pour les artistes, respectez leur travail voilà, ou alors créditez-les si vous utilisez leur dessin!
Comme cette personne vient de le faire, en disant que c'est TutoDraw qu'il l'avait fait.
Alors. Voilà mon squeezie FanArt, désolé je l'ai fait vite.
Cheveux qu'on a fini par aimer. Oh ça me touche.
Yeux super beaux(c'est la véritée ;-) )
Oh arrête!
Virilité.
*Cri viril*
Passion.
OH PU**** WHAOU!
Merci Julieta Chaparro.
Oh, ça fait du "The Last Guardian"!
J'ai pensé que ça te fera chaud au cœur!
Alors ça par exemple c'est obligé, c'est un mec qui a totalement volé ce FanArt!
Mais mec non fais pas ça !
Je sais pas qui a fait ce FanArt mais en tous cas il est très bien.
OHHH! Trico et Squeezie.
Wahhh! C'est tellement touchant!
Un grand bravo à Brohan pour ce dessin!
Alors là on est sur un dessin de qualité similaire.
D'accord donc tu m'as fait avec un corps de cheval déjà... C'est un manque de respect considérable.
C'est un morpion pas des abdos.
*Rire*
Ok, +1 pour la blague qui m'a fait rire!
Oh la laaaaaa!
"J'ai passer plus de 4heures dessus"
Et ! C'est tiré d'une photo que j'avais prise au japon dans un bar à Shiba, où il y avait deux Shibas en plein air qui étaient trop mignons.
Voilà, je vous mets les photos, suivez-moi sur instragram n'hésitez pas, hein!
Auto-promo calée, comme personne n'avait vu auparavant c'est magnifique.
Ouh là! Beaucoup trop d'éléments, squeezette, squeezie, le pervers de l'époque!
Pu**** ça c'est que des trucs de.. de mes anciennes vidéos, avec la lampe et tout, on se souvient de tout ça, la nostalgie elle est présente.
Wow! Alors, petite référence à mon logo YouTube actuel, petite référence au handspinner qui fait plaisir ou pas.
Trico dans le fond! Iron man parce j'adore Iron man, Bob l'éponge parce j'ai doublé une mouette dans Bob l'éponge.
Pu*** le nombre de références c'est fou! La lampe avec des ailes, moi-même ici présent avec la tenue que j'ai essayé pendant le live de cyprien!
On s'en souvient!
Norman : Cet homme a une érection
Norman: On va pas se mentir
*Rire de Squeezie, puis Cyprien et Norman*
Hyper cool bravo "Fanny Quinn" vous avez vraiment du talent nan mais c'est fou.
Bon à part cette personne, mais sinon les autres vous avez tous du talent hein!
Oh! Sympa, bravo.
"Axelle" Et c'est lui qui le poste. Mais tu n'es pas Axelle! Pourquoi voles-tu des pu**** de dessins sur Google?!
Je sais pas si c'est un filtre ou un vrai dessin. Des fois vous faites des dessins tellement stylés que je ne saurais pas dire si c'est un filtre ou pas. C'est horrible hein !
Oh! "Mon fanart de Squeezie n'est pas dans mes photos peut-être parce que c'est un commentaire je dois encore m'habituer à Twitter"
Mais ne t'en fais pas Luurei nous l'avons vu il est extrêment beau!
Jumbo n'a jamais été aussi stylé d'ailleurs on dirait un type (ou tigre) de la savane on ne dirait plus un chat domestique nul qui a la tête écrasée!
Il est super bien.
Ah! Pu****! Il y a du level mon gars ça fait plaisir !
Oh! Pu*** il est cool! Pu*** mais il y en a vous prenez un.. un dictionnaire voilà je vais le caler dans toutes mes vidéos maintenant
et en une heure vous faites un truc mais mec en dix ans j'arriverais pas à le faire c'est..
*Cri de douleur 100% viril de la part de squeezie*
*Autre cri de douleur*
Ah! C'est lourd un dictionnaire!
Pu*** l'angle pile qui fait mal!
Mais c'est pas un fanart c'est une photo alors attends regarde je vais donner la.. les différences entre les deux.
*musique calme*
et une photo..:
C'est clair? C'est Alain Rey qui le dit, ceci est donc une photographie c'est perdu.
Oh la laaaaa!
Mais mec, tu m'as détruit le visage.. J’espère ne jamais avoir ce visage un jour..
A moins d'un accident de voiture ça devrait pas arriver, mais pu***
Pu*** mec, même mon IPhone, l'accident l'a déformé quoi!
OOOOOHH on rigoooole c'est boon un moment on a le droit de s'amuser!
J'suis le premier à vanner mes dessins!
*lis* "Squeez.. Squeez.." OH pu*** de me***!
Oh j'regarde pas le dessin!
Alors là, comme tu m'as en***** le nom je regarde pas le dessin!
Oh il est beauuuuuu!
"Je  le reposte parce que j'avais oublié ma signature"
"Sarachu", et bien tu fais bien de mettre une signature!
Je vous invite d’ailleurs tous les artistes à faire ça en petit comme ça c'est discret et au au moins on pourra  créditer la bonne personne en le voyant
Wouhaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa!
Pu*** il m'a fait tellement stylé!
C'est vrai qu'en été j'ai les cheveux qui sont blonds un peu comme ça, mec merci pour ce FanArt en tout cas.
*Voix de forain*
Oui! Oui! Ouiii!
*Rire*
Le crabe il est pas du tout là.. Il est pas là! Il est là sur le côté!
Whaaaaaaa pu***!
C'est fait avec quoi ça? C'est fait au furet (fusain*)?
Ah je ressors des termes que j'ai appris en Arts Plastiques 6ème bon.
On est sur du Jumbo!
Du Jumbo carrément amélioré!
*lis* "Voilà la version finale en couleur"
Whaaa il est super, bravo!
Alors ça c'est une photo.. c'est pas du tout un dessin.. dois-je rappeler la définition.. de la photographie? Non je le ferai pas, quittez pas la video c'est bon!
Ca c'est très mignon avec ces petits poils qui ressemblent fortement à des poils d'aisselles
WOW il est fou!!
Mais en fait il y a plein de gens qui savent carrément bien dessiner, quoi!
Vous êtes des artistes les amis!
"Alors squezzie"...
Je vais partir du principe que quand tu te fais ch*** à passer 4 heures à  faire un dessin.
Tu sais écrire le pseudo de la personne pour qui tu le fais!
FLORENT IMPOSTEUR!
J'vais tirer des balles sur les imposteurs!
#virilitédesqueezie
*tire*
ET VOILA!
WOOOW ! Put****, étapes après étapes!
Tu fais une sorte de petit croquis où les traits sont pas nets,
ensuite tu repasses en faisant un trait bien net,
ensuite tu ajoutes de la couleur.
Et ensuite tu ajoutes un emoji!
*Rire*
WOOOOOAAH! C'est fou!
Une sorte de mixte entre Jumbo et Trico, c'est génial!!
"Tri-bo" on va l'appeler!
Alors ça c'est ce qu'on apelle un filtre instagram
"Jean michel trucage. Après tout je ne sais pas dessiner"
Bien tenté!
*Chuchoté*
Whoahhhhh!
*Lis*
J'avais déjà commencé le squeezie fan art il y a quelques mois du coup je l'ai fini pour l'occasion.
On dirait totalement diablo!
Choqué mais pas déçu he  in !!!
*Rire*
Un petit dessin en hommage au clip "Placement de produits" c'est mignon très mignon ça.
Pu**** mais vous adorez mes chats!
Vous aimez plus mes chats que moi même c'est fou!
Oh !
OH!
*Lis* "J'ai pas eu le temps de le finir mais je trouve que ça te ressemble déjà un peu!"
Ouais mais, par contre c'est extrêmement glauque!
Ouahh!
*Lis* "Bon alors désolé j'ai manqué de temps pour finir le décor, je peux finir et renvoyer si tu veux parce qu'il est moche là."
Nan mais arrête! Ca ménerve ça les artistes qui font ça là!
Respectez-vous pu**** c'est magnifique!!
Un artiste quand il fait un truc, il est obligé de dire: " Ouais mais c'est pas ouf" ... Ta gu****, ta gu****, c'est très bien ce que t'as fait!
Pu**** ayez confiance en vous! Il est trop bien, il est magnifique, pu**** jl'e fav!
*Clics de souris*
Oh pu****
De fu**. Mais pourquoi, c'est quoi cette oeil
De fu**. Mais pourquoi, c'est quoi cet oeil
Tu as eu un bug sur Paint, tu faisais CTRL+Z
ça marchait plus, trop tard l'oeil est comme ça. T'as fais exporter je l'envoie dans le doute.
*bruit d'admiration* Pu****, mais vous êtes trop talentueux , mecs.
La vidéo c'est que ça, c'est moi qui fait:
"Ouahh trop fort" ouah
ouah ouah ouah ouah ouah ouah ouah ouah ouah ouah !!
*Coups de feu* Ho Ho ... Ho putain ho il est trop stylé
Ouahh Mccree, Jacky Chan, le Crabe
Il y a vraiment des éléments qui vous ont marqués dans les vidéos c'est marrant vous retenez vraiment ça
Vous les mettez sur vos dessins quoi
Fait en 3h ne jugez pas il est pas super vu que j'ai 13 ans et encore beaucoup de défauts
Mais arrêtez de vous critiquer
Il est très bien, en dehors du fait que j'ai des trous dans les cheveux
et des énormes crottes d'oeil mais sinon ça va ... non j'rigole il est très bien
là y a un problème *rigole*
wouah putain c'est cool
Dumbo ! Ah d'accord le respect est mort ! *lis la bulle sur le dessin*
Il est très très bien ce dessin, bravo Camille
"Je  me permets de reposter mon Squeezie fan art pour que Squeezie le voie, ça représente beaucoup de travail" Bah bravo, très stylé!
J'aime bien comme y a vraiment des styles différents selon les artistes, c'est vraiment fou
Eh mais Jumbo vous le faites toujours plus mignon que ce qu'il est c'est trop drôle
Mais il est attachant ce chat... Il est tellement bête et naïf je l'aime trop
Ooooh! "Ne change rien à ta coupe #SqueezieFanArt"
Je sais pas si ma réaction c'est lié au fait que le dessin est stylé ou au fait qu'il m'ait détruit vis à vis de ma coupe de cheveux
Mec, celui-là je le prend, il est incroyable
Bah vous voyez, lui par exemple il a vraiment sa touch quoi, c'est vraiment puissant
Waw, on dirait un mec qui fait des caricatures dans le journal
je sais pas si c'est un compliment ce que j'ai dit mais dans ma tête c'était un compliment
Bravo "Gox " et non pas "Matteo Siboulette"
qui s'amuse à le voler
Et dont le nom de famille et en faite une épice !
Ah ! Il a dessiner mon bureau ! Jumbo ici...
Put*** c'est mignon ça , par contre les visages euh , y'avait la flemme
(lis) Je l'ai refait de mes propres mains
Mais je te crois pas...
Ce pauvre mec c'est fait voler son dessin 18 fois quoi
c'est déjà fait que quand tu tape "Squeezie fan'art" tu doit apparaître en premier
EH VOILA ! BRAVO ( tape des mains )
(lis) "Gox-blogger"
Eh bha tu c'est quoi on va aller sur son blog
J'adore il a était fait en 2015 en plus y'a 2 ans ce dessin mais il est très bien bravo Gox
Ah il est trop cool celui là ! Tu m'a fais tellement plus stylé que je ne le suis vraiment
Génial le micro avec le bras, l’écran, écran...C'est génial
Ça me fait penser à professeur Sakamotto ou je sais plus comment il s’appelle
C'est la meilleur vidéo du monde...
OUI!! C'est ça ! C'est trop bien, en gros c'est un mec dans un lycée, ( put*** je pars en hors sujet ) mais en gros c'est un mec dans un lycée
Qu'a trop la classe, qui vraiment il a trop de charisme il est trop fort
Et y'a des gens des fois qui essaye de lui faire des petits coup de pu**
Donc la il répond parfaitement à une question du prof genre il est très précis et tout
Ah et lui il a le seum il va faire la blague du je te rtire ta chaise
(Le silence)
(bruit de chaise)
(RIRE de Squeezie) + tape des mains
Y'a (?) qui a tellement la classe que quand tu lui retire sa chaise
Bah il est quand même assit  dans le vide
regarder ça m'a trop fait penser à ça quoi
Oh le crabe édition euh put***
(lit) "Fan'art de mes abonnés
AH c'est génial il a vraiment créée un univers
(lit)"CRABONNER ; 8,7 millions , mon tatouage
Haha genre c'est lui le youtubeur
Vlog au ski! ( voix viril ) c'est trop bien mec, trop d'imagination
Bravo" Noe"
Oh, référence à la vidéo ou on doit jouer Staline
( lit )Moi aussi mon petit fan'art qui s'inspire des propagandes des communistes à l'époque de Staline, en ésperant qu'il te plaise!
Oh put*** j'avais pas vu mais genre c'est le tatouge crabe sur les drapeaux
Super bien fait Bravo
Ça c'est moi en mode euh.. comment elle s'appelle ...put*** comment elle s'appelle...AAHH
( danse de la part de Squeezie hyper stylé)
TAG****!! ok
Ooooh . ( lit ) "SON NOM EST SQUEEEEEEZEH"
Non mais y'en a vous allez faire carrière dans le dessin
( lit ) "J'ai adoré te dessiner, le dessin c'est m'a passion! J’espère que tu vas l'aimer!"
Mais la vérité c'est que c'est un filtre instagrame sur laquelle tu as mis l'option débrouiller à 100%
OOh, put*** mais mec, un "Squeezamon" qui évolue
tu pense mec qu'on sera comme ça?
Attend ça se trouve il a vue le futur !
Dans 4 ans j'aurais totalement cette gueule , avec une grande moustache comme ça, dont un hand spinner
Nan bah nan c'est bon on arrête tout
( lit ) "J'vois pas mal de dessin actuellement qui n'ont pas les partages qu'il mérite...Merci les voleurs, SURTOUT continuez
( rit ) Il a mis l'image du jeu THIEF en mode... à vouloire qu'il ai la main sur ce dessin
Mais c'est vrai que celui-là c'est celui qui a été le plus volé de tous quoi c'est abuser! Pauvre Gox quoi on l'aime!
( cris ultra viril ) OOOH, en mode Joan Cornella
OLALALALA! Ché pas si vous connaissez cette artiste, c'est des imitrage et voilà il fait tous ces perso comme ça!
olala, mais la y'a trop de niveau la d'un coup qu'est ce qu'il ce passe là !
Oooh avec Lucio et une petite auréole d'ange c'est mignon
J'ai prit des joues mon gars j'ai pris 6 kilos! Il est très bien.
( lit ) "Environ 5h30 de travaille, j'y ai mis tout mon cœur
Il est super put*** ! Référence à la video hand spinner, il est vraiment trop bien
Bravo "Melanie"
C'EST QUOI CES TETONS NON MAIS OH !
Mai t'as pas honte!?
OH c'est beau! Enfaite les jeux de lumière ça embellie tellemnet un dessin....
( rit+tape des mains) Il a totallemnet prit un screen d'un jeu vidéo, il a barrer le nom du mec il a mit " Lucas "
A y'en a qui sont malins pour contourné la loi.
Aller beau gosse là j'aime bien ce style put***, Bravo " Mika Design", il est hyper bien!
Moi est mon frère, c'est fou comme vous arrangez nos nez, enfin surtout mon frère en l'occurrence
OOOOH PUT***
( lit ) " NekoChanDessin " bien joué !
A y'a le crabe ici donc je sais que sais bien moi que t'as dessiné
( lit ) " En revenant du Japon Squeezie nous à caché sa nouvelle passion! Banderole imposée suite à de nombreux fans art volés ici.
Tu as très bien fait, n'hésiter pas à marquer votre nom sur les dessins.
( voix de racaille ) EH moi je protège tout les artistes maintenant y'a quoi !?
OOOOH vous avez pas envie de m'adopter?
Vous adopter qui entre les deux?...
( le silence... )
Bah Trico bien-sur
OH put*** celui-là mais sur le cul il est tllemnet réaliste mec!
La taille de ce front, la taille de ce bras il est fou
Ah put*** bravo Nelson, enfin si tu es vraiment le créateur?
Tu ne l'as pas volé?
Ou été tu tout à l'heure à 14h?
Tu peux m'envoyé ton historique par screen s'il te plait?
Eh pour finir j'aurais un petit dessin a vous montrer moi en exclu, ça vas être rigolo...
( lit ) " et voilà...j'en suis super fier...2H de travaille qd même
Put*** le problème c'est que c'est pas moi  mais sinon il est vraiment bien
( rit ) Seb qui nous dit : " j'ai fait une peinture à l'huile vite fait en 10 minute juste pour participer
waw mec, Seb je savais pas que tu avis des talents de peintre comme ça c'est fou mec
WAW Maxess qui nous a fait un fan'art digne des plus grands!
Merci Maxenss!
( lit ) Tiens! Eh puis j'ai d'autr dessins de tte beauté sur ma chaine YOUTEUB si jamais!
ParodieSport sa chaîne YouTube
Et c'est absolument magnifique ce dessin est beau, de toute beauté
Bravo mec ...
Aller hop ... ( s'abonne à Saril DRAW )
( encore le silence )
On dirait un photo! Mec c'est fou
c'est une photo moi pour moi, les cheuveux, les cheuveux t'a détouré,
Attend y'a une vidéo, je veux voir la vidéo...
Comment de là tu passe a la version coloré ou on dirait un photo?!
c'est vraiment un dessin que quelqu'un a fait?
alors ça je veux voir, comment t'ajoute la couleur?
Ok tu fais une couche comme ça uniforme...
Ensuite tu tape dedans pour éclaircir les endroits manuellement
Et ensuite tu fais ça avec toute la peau mais c'est FOUUU
Ensuite tu vas faire pareil avec les cheveux et tu sera bon ?
olala mais là mais c'est incroyable. Eh mais le talent !
Alors je voulais juste vous montrer les fans'art qui ont été fait y'a un moment
que j'avais vu et que j'ai jamais pus remercier ceux qui l'avait fait
Waw alors déjà y'a " Lou gribouille " qui avait fait un truc de malade avec plein de youtubeurs
y'a aussi celui-là a l'époque qui était complètement dingue
2014 C'est à l'ancienne hein
Oh il est bien celui-là aussi put*** par rapport au jeu " Hello Neighbor "
Celui ci aussi qui est complètement ouf aussi enfin bref
y'a vraiment des gens qui poste des dessin régulièrement, des fans'art, donc merci a tout ces gens aussi ..
Et merci à tout ceux qui ont participer sur twitter  ça m'a fait hyper chaud au coeur .
Vous êtes bourrez de talent c'est dingue
Et comme promis attention je vais vous monter un truc ...
En faite je devait refaire le décore y'a un moment mais je l'ai toujours pas fait, faudrais que je le face...
Et je voulais afficher ça. C'est quelque chose que j'ai ramené de mon dernier voyage au Japon
Avec mon frère et mon père...
( Musique de surprise ...)
c'est tout simplement une caricature de mon frère mon père et moi.
En " One punche, DBZ, et Naruto "
voilà je vous montre normalement ça sera afficher plus tard là
C'est un Japonaise qui était bourrée de talent dans un centre commercial,
Et j'ai craqué et je me suis dit vasy
( voix de racaille ) " Obligé on fait une caricature "
Elle fait ça vraiment en 10 minutes c'est impressionnant
bon après elle a pas autant de talent que vous mais ça faut pas lui dire
Merci à tous d'avoir participé, je suis désolé si y'en qui n'ont pas vu leur dessins passer dans la vidéo mais j'ai
reçu tellement de dessins que j'aurai du faire une vidéo de 28 heures pour tous les montrer !
Merci beaucoup dans tous les cas, si vous avez fais un dessin, que ça vous ait pris 10min ou 8h, c'est hyper mignon de votre part,
ne volez jamais des dessins d'autres personnes, c'est vraiment pas cool pour eux,
c'est vraiment du taf et, c'est dur de se créer une communauté etc et quand tu te fais voler comme ça
gratuitement ça fout les boules.
Ne faites pas ça sinon je vous défonce moi-même ! Regarde la caméra elle même elle vous défonce, elle s'est éteinte la pu**
et vu que c'est la fin je change pas la batterie je vous dit au revoir sur fond noir
Aller SALUT ! *rire*